[MUSIC PLAYING]
EDGERTON: Now,
gentlemen and ladies,
the electronic flash
equipment always
consists of three parts, an
energy source and a device
for storing the energy
and discharging suddenly
into a converter, which
we call a flash lamp.
The object of this
talk this morning
is to discuss flash
lamps to help prepare you
for the experiment that you're
going to do on flash lamps.
Electrically, a flash lamp is
an extremely interesting thing.
Because it's completely
non-linear in every possible
way, shape, and form.
And every lamp is individual.
It's different than other lamps.
So when you get
through experimenting,
I hope that you
will be convinced
that this type of device
does have these variations.
Here's a typical
electronic flash lamp.
This is one of the large
real powerful ones that's
used for stimulating lasers.
It's just, discharges capacitor,
a very large capacitor
with an inductor and series.
And one of the biggest
uses of flash tubes
is for making laser lights.
If I put a high voltage on
this, I can break it down.
You can see the
discharge in the device.
There's about 40,000
volts coming out of this.
That's the kind of electricity
that doesn't hurt you.
You don't treat other kinds of--
electricity the same way.
I did that for effect.
You can try this yourself.
Don't jump too high when
you try it the first time.
I have a small flash tube
on this display equipment.
This is one of them
that you will be using.
There are four equipments
like this in the laboratory.
So no one can, three of you
can work simultaneously.
And I have a flash tube on here.
And I'm, you'll notice there's
a sound associated with this.
When the sound is on,
the juice is going in.
And there's a variac.
And I'm watching the voltage,
2,000 volts, 2,500 volts,
as high as I can go on
this particular unit.
And of course, nothing happens.
Because I am below the
self-starting voltage.
Every flash lamp has a
And usually we cannot reach this
in the laboratory with without
going to a lot of trouble.
The self-starting voltage
on that little lamp
is probably over 4,000 volts.
So it'll be off of this scale.
But I can make the
lamp go at my command
by putting on a stimulator.
By an external electrode,
it breaks down.
And if you look
closely, you can see
a discharge that follows the
same path as the spark wire.
This is a very important
aspect of this whole concept,
is be able to control the
flash to occur at the time
as you wish it to occur.
Now I'll put on my
little spark coil.
And I will turn
on a high voltage
and bring it up to 2,500 volts.
And I'll turn on the spark.
And of course, nothing
happens because I'm
down here at too low voltage.
So I'll run the voltage
up with this tenuator.
This controls the frequency
at which it flashes.
So that's 10.
That's about 2KV.
That starts very good.
2KV down here at
about 3,500 volts,
so I get a point right there.
Now I want to go down
to about 2,000 volts
where this tube is normally
supposed to be used--
2,000 volts, maybe
a little bit less.
Now I have to put more
voltage on to make it go,
going up, going up.
Thanks, ouch, it's still on.
There we go.
I've got about 2,000
volts on there now.
And the spark voltage
is still very reliable.
Now this is the
point, about this,
I want you to understand
is that reliability is bad.
So sometimes it goes.
Sometimes it doesn't go.
So I'm up around 2,000 volts.
And I'm putting on, according to
this curve, about 3,000 volts,
somewhere in here.
And I get some uncertainties.
Let's make, if down here we
get zeros, up here we get Xs.
But we get some
zeros in between.
If I go to 1KV, let's
see what happens then.
You're going to have a lot
of fun turning these knobs,
trying to figure
out what's going on.
There we are.
That's, the uncertainty
point is around 30
on here, which is about 6,000
volts, so up in here somewhere,
the uncertainty value for 1KV.
There is a curve,
a bottom curve,
which delineates the
no go area, no go.
This is a place
to stay away from.
There's another
area which is maybe.
And up here is yes, go.
Well, if you ever design
a flash equipment,
you want it to be
in this area and be
up here in good and strong.
So it never gets
down into this point.
There's nothing
more discouraging
than to work marginally
with a flash unit
where you haven't
got enough spark.
So the rule here is put plenty
plenty of zip into this thing
so that it will go.
Now the object of
this first experiment,
I haven't read the sheet,
is to determine that curve
for one of these tubes.
Most these tubes, I think
we've got enough for everybody.
You'll be able to select out of
this pile one of these tubes.
And there are many
different shapes
and sizes and dimensions.
And you can have the tube
that you test if you want it.
You have your opportunity of
testing as many of these tubes
as you want.
If there's a dud,
leave it in the box.
Don't take it.
But only take a good one.
How do you tell a good tube?
First of all, it should
be able to start at,
have a minimum starting
voltage somewhere down in here
around 400 volts.
If it will not start at
400 volts, throw it out.
In other words, and
also if you have
one that starts with a
3,000 or 4,000 volts on it,
throw it out.
What you want is
to get a tube that
will be in the range
of which you want
to use that particular tube.
The electrical
characteristics of the tubes
are fascinating to me.
Of course, the light output
is the most important thing.
But as electrical people,
we must learn something
about how they
operate electrically.
You'll notice in
this display, there's
a very nice little
filament of electricity
that tends to follow
the starting wire.
If I put more energy in,
this film, it gets bigger.
And also gives quite a bit more
light, and it fills the tube.
And that, of course,
is what we want.
When we use a lamp, we
want it to be efficient.
And we want to get lots and
lots of light out of it.
Now, the electrical
characteristics of these tubes
are shown in a slide that
will come on the screen.
This is a slide of time
versus the voltage across.
The tube is the upper curve.
You'll notice it's marked wrong.
The current rises to a peak
and then decays to zero.
Usually the voltage comes down
and leaves a residual voltage
on the capacitor.
Now every flash
tube it should take
will have a different
characteristic of its type.
Some of these have these
little ripples in them.
And they're always different.
And this is one thing that
makes this type of experimenting
interesting is because
you never know for sure
what is going to come out.
As electrical engineers,
we're in such a habit
of depending on Ohm's law and
the other electrical waves
which calculates circuits
that we try to do everything
we can by calculation.
But when you work
with flash lamps,
you have to back off
every once in a while
and go to an analog
solution of the equations.
It's determined by what
the tube itself does.
The laws of the tube have not
been completely studied yet.
So we have to do as best we can
by calculating from examples
and then rushing
to the laboratory.
And in a few microseconds,
out comes the answer.
And it's usually different
than what you had.
But that is the real answer
for that particular tube.
So this is why people that
work with electronic flash
do lots and lots
of experimenting.
Because you have to
be in the laboratory.
And you have to do a lot of
these things on these nonlinear
devices by using the
thing itself in order
to find out what is going on.
The second slide
shows the same data
plotted on a volt ampere curve.
On the bottom is current.
On the top is volts.
At the upper left
hand corner, it
starts with the maximum voltage
you have a cross a tube,
such as 2,000 volts.
Then when the current
starts, this current
rises very rapidly to
thousands of amperes.
And then it decays slowly
as the capacitor discharges.
And it comes down to
a residual voltage,
a small voltage is
left on the capacitor.
Now, if the tube did
follow Ohm's law,
then you could draw
a resistance line.
Let's go back to
the slide once more.
There is a straight
line in that.
Can you back up to that resist--
back up to the other slide.
There is a resistance there.
You'll notice that straight
line is a resistance line.
And everybody that works with
flash units gets into a habit
very quickly of calculating
an approximate resistance.
You know that the
answers that you're
going to get with resistance
are going to be wrong.
But they're better than nothing.
And so you use them.
And one way in which to
calculate this resistance is
to use the maximum voltage
you have on the capacitor,
divide it by the
maximum current that you
get during a discharge.
And you'll notice
that that curve,
that straight line intersects
the real volt ampere
curve in several places.
And it gives you a
sort of an average.
And this is a useful concept.
Because if you don't
know the voltage,
you do know the
resistance, the tube
is defined that way,
you can immediately
calculate the maximum current,
as long as the current is
limited entirely by the tube.
Now the people that
stimulate lasers
also put an inductor in there.
So this whole thing collapses.
Because the inductor is what
determines the maximum peak
current that flows.
But the resistance
concept is still useful
because it enables you to
estimate for a capacitor
discharge the time in
which the thing collapses.
The next characteristic
I want to show you
is the one that you've
already experimented
with in the laboratory.
And you know this
from old times,
is the voltage from a
photo cell that tells you
the number of
[INAUDIBLE],, usually
in the millions of [INAUDIBLE]
as a function of time.
These curves have several
bumps and ripples on them.
They rise to a peak
value in a certain time
and it takes to
discharge to rise.
And then it decays
exponentially,
in an exponential form to zero.
Well those of us that
work in this field define
flash duration as the time
between third peak, which
is shown very clearly in this
slide that shows the time
duration of a flash.
Now how can all
this information be
presented into a form
where you can use it
for designing other tubes
or for understanding
some kind of a tube?
This has all been, all
information on a standard tube
has been assembled on this
sheet that I'll hand you out
at the end of the class.
It shows the dimensions
of the flash tube.
And we're going to look at
these curves on the view
graph in a minute and try
to explain to you what
they mean so that you'll be
able to use this information.
The lamp on which this
experimental work was done
was a six inch lamp, about that
long, of this four millimeter
inside diameter,
filled with xenon gas
at about 20 centimeters.
That's about a fifth
of an atmosphere.
It's excited externally.
And the variables that
you have are the voltage
across the tube,
that capacitance you
have connected across the tube.
And you want to
know a lot of things
about this when you
want to apply it
to some particular problem.
So I'll go over the view graph
and show you these curves.
Well, these are things
that we've picked out.
Maybe they're the right things.
Maybe they're not.
But the first one that
we're interested in
is, how much peak
current do you get?
If you're designing a circuit,
how many thousands of amperes
do you get?
Well, here is a curve
of the peak current.
This goes up to
about 3,000 amperes.
And it's done for
capacities that
go from one microfarad to 200
microfarad and voltages that go
from 500 volts to 3,500 volts.
So there's a tremendous
range of things that
are covered in this experiment.
And I think you realize
that the data for this
was obtained by going
into the laboratory
and measuring the peak light
as a function of these things
and mounting them
on this log plot
so that you could get the whole
data on that particular chart.
The full rated value
of that particular tube
is 100 microfarad
at 2,000 volts.
And so here, 2,000 volts,
you read 1,200 amperes.
And if you want to know
the lamp resistance,
you divide 2,000 by 1,200.
And it's equal to approximately
2 ohms, 2 ohms, close enough.
So you say that is a 2 ohm lamp.
And from then on, you can
deal with it as a 2 ohm lamp.
Other things that are of
interest is the peak light.
If you're doing experiment
in the laboratory
and you want to know how
many millions of candlepower
are coming out,
you can measure it.
And you go from one million,
10 million, 100 million,
doesn't go up that high,
with same way capacitors.
Go from one microfarad
to 200 microfarad.
And the voltage
covers the same range.
This again covers a tremendous
range of light over this range.
Now, this standard tube
at full load rating
again reads eight
million, 500, 8.5 times 10
to the sixth candlepower light.
Quite often, when we wish to
test the photoelectric cell
in a laboratory or some device,
we drag out this six inch tube.
We put a capacitor of
100 microfarad across it
at 2,000 volts.
We flash it.
And out will come
eight and a half
million candlepower,
which makes it easy
for us to do our experiments.
This curve is very important,
one flash duration.
Because the first
thing that you wish
to know when you do any
experiments on a subject,
to stop its motion, you need to
know what the flash duration.
The flash duration is too
long, you'll get a blur.
So here is flash duration
running from 10 microseconds
up to 500 microseconds for
capacities going from 1 to 100.
For the different
voltages, you'll
notice that there's a
tendency for it to be flat.
It would be flat if this
resistance were constant.
But it's not constant.
The resistance goes up as
you go to lower voltages.
And that means
these curves go up.
And the discharge lasts longer.
In other words, if you have a
small capacitor on a flash lamp
like I showed you, you will
have a nice little, skinny, dim
filament, which
doesn't go anywhere
near as high and light level
and it lasts a much longer time.
So this curve is
a very useful one.
Now, the final
curve, and I think
one of the most useful ones,
is the one of efficiency.
Efficiency is given on the
axis in candlepower per watt.
If you could double the
efficiency of a flash tube,
it would be a great thing.
So how do you get the
efficiency higher than 5?
I just don't know.
But anyway, these
are the highs as far
as we've been able to get it.
But you'll notice
that they come up.
Again, these are a function
of capacity and voltage.
And you would think
that you would
be able to design all the flash
units to be efficiency of 5.
Well, that's a good idea.
We should keep working on
it and try to get those up.
So I think these four curves,
you'll have copies of these
to take home with you.
And you can check these
in the lab or as you wish.
And you can help to use these
for designing other flash
tubes.
All the information on
designing other flash tubes
is given in this book that
you've probably heard about.
And the rules are quite
simple on how to do this.
Suppose you want to make
your tube twice as long.
The physics of the
tube require that you
have exactly the same
voltage per unit length.
So if you have a 6 inch
tube with 2,000 volts on it
and you make a 12 inch tube, how
many volts do you need on it?
STUDENT: 4,000.
INSTRUCTOR: Hooray, 4,000.
If you put 100 watt
seconds into a 6 inch tube,
how many watt seconds do you
have to put in the others?
The other requirement,
you have to put
that same number of watt
seconds per cubic centimeter
in these two tubes.
So you'd have to put
200 in the second tube.
And the reasons for this are
that the molecules of xenon
that are in here
are swimming around,
all they know is that they
have so many joules or watt
seconds per molecule and
that the electrical gradient
in here, which is causing them
to ionize, is exactly the same.
And if you could get out one
xenon molecule from this thing
and look at it with
an eyeglass, it
would react exactly the
same in these two tubes.
And it would not know whether
it was in a 6 inch tube or a 12
inch tube or 1,000 inch tube.
So those rules are simple
and straightforward.
And it's all documented
in the technique.
And all I can
guarantee to you when
you use this theory is that
you'll get the wrong answer.
Because this theory does not
include the electrode effects
and the wall effects.
So what you do is
use the theory.
You can do it quick.
And you grind out what the
new tube will probably do.
And do I need to tell you?
You rush into the
laboratory and clip it
onto one of these various
machines that we have there,
put the telescope
up, and bang, out
comes a number, which
will tell you exactly
how far off your theory is.
We have used this technique
a great deal in our various,
development of very
large strobe equipment.
And it's very useful
there, like the one
up on top of the prudential
building is a tube.
It's about that long.
And it's a tube about that big.
And there's about 5,000
watt seconds into it.
And just by taking these
dimensional effects,
we can hook it up.
We can find out what it will
do as an optical device.
We can get the flash duration.
We can get the efficiency.
And all these other factors
that we need to know
can immediately come out
via a preliminary try at it.
Now, the next thing
I have to show you as
is discussed as a
problem that I do not
know the answer to very well.
And it still is one of the most
important things in all flash
equipment.
And that is the
life of the tube.
When most people ask me, what
is the life of the flash lamp?
I say, well, it's
usually too long.
Of course, that's the view of
the man in the factory that's
making them.
He wants it to go on
a lot of production.
But you can make a
flash lamp that will run
for years and years and years.
In fact, the one on the
Museum of Science, I think,
has been up there about
eight or 10 years.
It quit about five years ago.
And I rushed over.
And I said, glory be.
The thing is finally broke.
But somebody pulled the
plug out of the wall.
And it is still going.
And whenever you see the Museum
of Science, that little blinker
up there, it is, let's see
that curve of efficiency.
Curve of efficiency, this
is a log plot starting
at the bottom with one.
You don't have to go
below a one flash.
I hope none of you will
have that experience,
although it's a lot of fun.
One flash, our lab
is full of pieces.
Then it goes to 10, 100.
Most of the tubes,
flash tubes are
made have a life of 10 flashes.
And tubes of this type,
I think that's a 38.
No, that's a different number.
That's the tube they're
talking about on that curve.
It's connected in a
series with an inductor.
And that curve, let's
look at the curve again.
We run that curve up as
a function of voltage.
And you'll notice, it goes
to 1,000 volts and then 2,000
volts.
And then at 1, there's
a kind of a star.
That's where we increase
the xenon concentration
in the strobe alley.
That xenon comes out there
and gives you a increase of,
also tube flies around the room.
And it's not too
healthy a place.
If you're going to
do this experiment,
get something between
you and the lamp.
Because the glass
doesn't go very fast.
But it does get in your hair
and causes all kinds of trouble.
Now, the 10, how do you
rate a 10 lamp flash?
It doesn't blow up
after 10 flashes.
What happens is that the
electrodes will melt away.
The tube will get
dark and black.
And so its efficiency
will reduce.
So this type of a
lamp, which is used
for stimulating these
very powerful lasers,
they give us a tremendous whack.
Its life is only 10 flashes.
Then you throw it out and
put in four or five new ones.
On the other end of the scale,
at the top end of that curve,
it goes up to 1,000
and 10,000 and 100,000.
Most of the
electronic flash units
that are used in small
portable equipments run around,
oh, 100,000.
They guarantee 10,000.
But you'll have a hard
time counting after 10,000.
Most of them will
run over 10,000.
But the ones that you
want to put in beacons
run one million and 10 million.
And I think the one over
there on the Museum of Science
has run actually about
somewhere around 100 million.
And it's still going strong.
Of course, this is done by
reducing the energy in the tube
and tending to your business.
So this curve is a very
interesting one to follow.
And it's going to become more
important as time goes on.
Because one of the advantages
of using electronic flash lamp
as a beacon in a lighthouse
or something is a flash,
is a point that it will
flash for a long, long time
without attention.
When I was in high school,
I lived in a prairie town
out in Nebraska that
had a courthouse.
It went up about
a thousand miles.
Snow's only 500, 600 feet.
But one of my jobs as
a high school student
was to go up there,
open the window,
and reach out and unscrew a 200
watt bulb when it burned out.
And I can still remember how,
it looked like it was way up.
So now that courthouse has
four 10 watt second xenon flash
tubes in it.
And I service it from Boston
about once every six months.
They keep right on going.
So I'm still doing the
same job I did in 1920 when
I was a high school student.
I still climb up that darn
tower and open the window.
But I don't have to
reach out so far.
And if any of you go out
through the prairie in Nebraska,
there will be one
unique courthouse.
There's one every 25 miles.
And that's in rural Nebraska.
That's the only one out there
with four strobes on it.
So it's quite distinctive.
In fact, people driving on
the road come trudging in
and say, what are those
blinking lights doing
on that courthouse?
I'm going to be out
there next week.
I'm going to take
a few spare tubes.
And I'll dust them off,
clean them off, put them in.
But those tubes will
last a long, long time.
This is very important for
lighthouses and for beacons.
You don't want to
change them often.
The tungsten lamp, if
it's used efficiently,
will never run
more than a month.
If it's used inefficiently,
it'll run longer.
Xenon flash tubes,
of course, will run,
nobody really has the
patience to find out
how long they actually will go.
Now I have just a few slides at
the end to kind of wind us up.
And I thought I'd show you a few
pictures, a few applications,
this one.
Next slide will show, I'm very
much interested in underwater.
Here, the strobe is not used
because of its short speed.
It's not used because if its,
any purpose, but the ability
to get out a small battery,
enough light to take hundreds
and hundreds of pictures.
And it's been my pleasure
to work in cameras.
We've had them down, oh, we've
had them down five miles deep.
And they're taking pictures
of the bottom of the ocean.
There's an awful lot of
it to be photographed.
And we're still working
on this, the angle of it.
The next slide shows
a color picture
of a balloon with a
bullet going through it.
In case any of you
haven't done this,
when you shoot
through a balloon,
there's several possibilities.
If the balloon is only
partially deflated,
then the bullet
will go in and out.
And it will not tear.
The air will just squirt
out through this hole.
And you'll notice that
there's a ring, a wave where,
it's coming out from
where the bullet went in.
The other thing is to blow
the balloon up very tight.
And when you shoot the bullet
through it, it will tear.
If you put the
light around back,
you'll see a little line going
through where this tear occurs.
The next slide shows a
golfer with mother flash.
You've had a chance to do some
of this in the laboratory.
And I hope you'll
keep this in mind.
Because this is one of
the most interesting types
of photography
there is, where you
put a time sequence of
a whole lot of pictures
onto a stationary film
so that you've got
a time record of what goes on.
And I don't need to
tell you that you have
to move your lights around.
So that you do not
light the background,
you use a black background.
You use of white subject
and a lot of contrast
and so forth and so on.
And the last slide,
there's one more
in there that shows MIT from,
with a 80,000 watt second
strobe.
There's one of these
hanging in Strobe Alley,
this one made in 1944
with 80,000 watt seconds
and two giant tubes in a big
airplane flying up in the sky.
And someday I hope to build
a real powerful strobe, not
one of these types.
So this concludes this lecture.
And I hope that all of you
will have some good experiences
in the laboratory.